what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a fresh and fit clip
titled she wants to go out tell her this
um it just seemed like a funny clip to
me so i decided i'm going to react to it
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel as you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers that's a big goal for the
channel and each and every one of you
helps while you're at it bring that
notification bell that way
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos
[Music]
she can't go out with her girls when
she's in a relationship with you
no no what so so you just
excuse me so i'm curious in the
manosphere do you think it's like both
ways
because i don't think it should like
either or
oh and i know that's scary for a lot of
women like when i say that yeah
because i understand and what do you
define as go out
like a restaurant i don't think would be
bad but like going clubbing yeah
i don't think you should be going where
you say you said now you're putting
yourself in a position
to open i understand too because she's
going to be in a group of females who's
going to be infected with that [ __ ]
music
yeah i get it like but where does that
boundary of like
keeping her in a box and her having her
freedom not to have those wrong
intentions of those open doors
but where does she get to be herself and
not have to think about
myra more or or you know with the
children
what if you have kids you don't have
time to go to the club
[Applause]
don't get me wrong i'm not i'm not the
the
girls night out type of woman i'm not
going
i didn't even do that when i was younger
like the whole clubbing and thing i
didn't do that i was more
i've always been like more homebody so
me personally i don't have a problem
not going out i don't have a me i love
to cook i don't have a problem cooking i
don't have a problem
you know being at home with my kids but
there is at least
one time or one day out of the month
that i want to go out
for myself do you have a problem with
that
hey go out where that's the question can
i go to the club
not go to the club because i want to go
to the club but i love to dance
and when i'm at home with my kids or i'm
cooking or i'm cleaning or i'm washing
the dishes or i'm washing my clothes
or i have to take care of my man or i
have to work on my business
like i i like to dance so the way that i
express myself or release all these
emotions is
through dancing so there is some times
that i want to go out at least
not even once a month once every two
months every three months i want to go
out and just dance and just like
release you know all these tensions only
all these emotions but it's not
it's not because you know you got that
key word release tension
yeah um yeah because i mean as as a
woman especially if you have kids like
you have a lot going on and you really
don't have
time for yourself so it's like i can be
taking a [ __ ] and my kids are right
there opening the door
but couldn't you do that at like a dance
class or something
like yo so um how about this option hire
a babysitter
right and then dance at home hire a
babysitter and dance
yeah just you know how just take them to
your you know someone's house
will be well it's about the environment
but i don't see why she couldn't go to
like a dance class
whatever and that's at home no so it's
like
you you i'm going to be incarcerated in
my home forever
i can't she wants to get out the house i
can't go out one night
for myself like it doesn't look it
doesn't even have to be to the club
it can be out to eat it can be out
to to the beach and sit down you know
i'll say this i can't answer for all men
but what i can tell you is this
because some guys are going to have
different boundaries right i'm giving
you my personal boundaries you know what
i'm saying because i
i study women all the time i'll be like
all day listen i've been
i've been doing this for six months i
just want to go to the beach and sit
down for
for an hour to would you have a problem
with that i mean
what i'm going with you you're not going
to go by yourself
like you know what i mean like that
that's how that's how i look at it like
this is going to sound awful but you got
to protect women from themselves man
and in today's day society you know with
the way
there are so oh my gosh
the beach that's that's a little crazy
that's how many bad habits that are
taught to women and actually encouraged
that are completely destructive to
families and relationships if you do
that then
sorry to cut you off if you do that then
you kind of lowkey saying
if i gotta save you from you you
literally saying i don't trust you
you're saying
the biggest [ __ ] ever i feel like
they're suffocating i feel like new
merch
yeah um you know
we're promoting the merch so okay so so
you're
okay so your argument is say one more
time you're basically you don't think
you need like alone
time like with your friends
like that that's a little too much say i
gotta go with you because i'm gonna
protect you from you so
initially you're saying and that's why
it's important to get
with someone that has values if you
don't trust her to go to the beach by
herself
even with like a couple girlfriends like
i don't know i think women need that
alone time i'm not saying you should go
to a club i definitely don't think
that's appropriate but
just like hanging out with your friends
hey i don't trust you and if you don't
trust them then why are you with them
basically what i'm saying i i think it's
funny because um
a lot of girls right they say yeah i
need my time for myself i need to like
get out and i get that you want to get
out the house you're tired of being home
however if you're really feeling your
dude and you're really into him
you're always going to want to be around
them so when you go to clubs you're like
yo you know what babe let's go to club
together i don't but you have to think
about like a marriage like i'm not
thinking about this as a short-term
relationship i'm thinking about a
marriage you're telling me if a girl
you're married to someone for 50 years
40 years 30 however long you want to be
married you're not gonna let her go to
the beach
are you nuts go without you or for
example let's you know what let's take a
weekend and let's take a trip
you're not gonna want to do it by
yourself so and then if your girlfriends
are single
and you go you're singing you know where
you're singing uh girlfriends is gonna
be like yo
i'm with my dude i have a dude you guys
are single you're going to influence me
to do some [ __ ] that i may not want to
do
so i get what you're saying but just
like i said before the open door
it's about the environment it's not you
don't have to go to a core policy what
about like dinner
if you open the open at the door you
don't know what's inside inside the room
and it may influence you to do something
that you don't want to do so i'm just
saying look
if you're going to go do your thing at
least you know what
let your man come through sometimes or
at least have that option there
so you know what come with me babe let's
let's go together but to go by yourself
to like a girls night out the club or
like a trip god damn that's like opening
hell's gates because you never know
what's going to happen oh fresh look
rita what's important oh it's in for
rent go to the club and dance no makeup
not showing your ass hey
without makeup and and things like that
like you get what i'm saying i'm not
i'm not that party girl i'm not you know
i
but i do like to dance or i do like to
have just one time you know
at least an hour so for me to recollect
my thoughts
you know because if i have so many
things going on my kids my son my
daughter their school their
their uh medical stuff you know my
business then i have
my my business partners then i have my
students
it's just so much that sometimes you
just you really and not only women
men too mentally you just need that
at least one hour to yourself to clear
your thoughts
to not have to worry about anything to
see how you can be a better
you know person all around be a better
girlfriend be a better mother be a
better
uh you know um mentor things like that
so
i do believe that that when it comes to
at least mental health you do
need it's to me at least it's necessary
that you take at least one hour for
yourself because
at least when quarantine started i was
going [ __ ] crazy
you act like you're not gonna get sick
of your partner in a marriage at some
point like
be inside these walls and and just my
yes my man was
he was like no you guys are staying home
i'm gonna do groceries i'm gonna do
laundry like he took care of that
but being in these four walls all
[ __ ] day doing the same thing over
and over and not being
able to go it's like yo i i want to go
to the table real fast okay so you want
to dance um
would you uh what about you like what
would you need to do
to like uh would you maintain your
instagram in a relationship would you
maintain
would you maintain still going you're
you're so you're fighting for girls
nights out
would you no no no no no not not a
girl's night out because i've even told
my mother
i've even told him babe take me i've
told him babe take me dancing
that's all i want to do just take me
down okay if he's with you that's not a
problem
and what if he tells me no then i
you can follow what he says period
okay so i have to follow this is where
myron goes way too far
way too far way men with genuine desire
for a guy don't consider clubbing with
their girls
their investment is with him oh this is
not true
that is not but what he says yeah all
right and if you disobey him he should
be he should walk away from you
okay all right i got you there but what
if he's not holding his end of the
bargain
that's that's that's that's the key
that's that i see that that's
i know that that i know that's that's a
condition but
all right babe let me express come with
me but you don't want to come with me
so then she has to stop doing something
she likes to do i'm not saying it has to
be a club but like a dance class or
something i don't see what that is the
issue
here's the thing i don't know if you
guys caught it but i said you gotta be
higher status right you gotta like
a man can have strong standards unless
he's not a strong man himself
okay so you have to be a certain caliber
of guy to be able to
have these types of terms but here's the
thing when you become that kind
i'm not gonna lie i don't think myron is
i'm
i just smell like insecurity from him i
don't know why
i just get that vibe man you can have
these demands
and then the girl's gotta pick what she
wants to do it's all my choices this
ain't no force
it's just that i have boundaries and i'm
not going to let you
take advantage of these boundaries like
you probably have in the past most women
walk over their men i'm going to keep it
a thousand
most women do whatever the [ __ ] they
want their on instagram showing their
ass
they're they're they're on doing clubs
girls nights out they
they're texting dudes they're doing all
this wild [ __ ] and the reason why is
because like i told you before most guys
are made in mills they think men and
women are the same
right and then on top of that most guys
are scared to step up to their girl and
tell them yo stop doing this
i mean they call everyone a beta most
guys
don't really think about that stuff like
in the real world most people don't
listen to the man of sphere they don't
really think about if men and
women are different or the same they
just live their life like this isn't
like the real world because
any time anytime a man puts his foot
down or represses female sexuality
it's considered misogynistic toxic or
insecure or
you're controlling but i don't think
it's but here's the difference like
she's talking about a hobby that she
genuinely likes
he's talking about going out clubbing so
i'm saying like can't there be a
compromise
and so if she likes to like go dancing
are you saying like she's never gonna
dance again if her husband doesn't like
to dance
so she has to give up that hobby and i'm
not someone who's gonna say you should
be going out and like clubbing and all
this stuff when you're in a relationship
i definitely don't think you should
but like this my way or the highway
nonsense you're gonna end up divorced
but let me know in the comments if you
agree or you disagree
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification bell as
you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers and i need each and every
one of you
to help me get there i will talk to you
guys next time